now I first tried out Android when I
tried out the HTC dream phone which is
the first commercial device that
launched with Android now more than 10
years ago at launch Android was known
for its appearance transparency and
openness and we're still stand by these
principles today and since then Android
has made its way into the hands of
billions of consumers and some of the
most demanding enterprise environments
and in order to protect all of our users
and their data security is a top
priority and we're making a measurable
progress and raising the bar across the
mobile ecosystem we run a vulnerability
rewards program which is a bounty
program with some of the highest payouts
in the industry paying up to $200,000
for a security exploit chain that
compromises your device high rewards
plus our open source code fosters a
vibrant community of researchers who
help us find bugs before they affect our
users and in 2018 there were zero
critical security vulnerabilities
affecting the Android platform that were
publicly disclosed without a security
update or mitigation available as
another data point there are a number of
vulnerability discovering the squash
closure competitions that invite hackers
from around the world to come a break
mobile devices and paid up to hundreds
of thousands of dollars to do so a
mobile phone our own which is one of the
most well-known competitions of this
kind Google pixel has a great track
record of being unbroken year after year
now we know that these results were
achieved on fully patched up-to-date
devices and that the ability to patch a
device is critical to a security posture
and we're doing a lot to increase patch
rates across the ecosystem at the
technical level we architected the
operating system to make patch a easy
for device makers and seamless for users
to make updates easy for device makers
and seamless for users and beyond the
technical level our ecosystem of
partners have come together to form a
strong collaboration to remove bare
and in q4 of 2018 we saw 84% more
devices receive a security update
compared to q4 the prior year now we
know that security threats come in many
forms and some of them like fishing and
spyware don't need to actually
compromise your device and bypass the
security model in order to harm users so
Android devices with Google services
have Google Play protects built in and
enabled by default we leverage a
combination of human security expertise
and state of the art machine learning to
define potentially harmful apps before
they find our users and in 2018 we saw a
20 percent year-over-year decline and
the proportion of devices that install
the potentially harmful app all of this
data plus a lot more as available in our
annual year and reveal report we also
published a quarterly transparency
report with details on the overall
health of the ecosystem to find links to
these reports along with a lot more
information visit the Android Security
Center website at Android comm slash
security okay so that was a quick
overview of how we're doing today now
developers in the audience and everyone
else in the audience probably came here
to learn more about what's new in
Android q and there were a lot of
changes they fall under three categories
privacy update ability and hardening now
privacy is a huge focus area for us and
has been for many years we made dozens
of changes across all aspects of the
operating system we're giving users a
lot more transparency over access to
their data we're giving users more
control over their location and with
further restricting app access to
persistent device identifiers now this
is just the tip of the iceberg there was
a talk yesterday at i/o focused on
privacy for Android so take a look at
the recording for that to learn more
next update ability
we're building upon the momentum that we
started with and with project rubble a
couple of years ago and this year we
launched project mayline with project
mainline a few system system components
including some security critical ones
will now be updated to rectly by Google
so for example the media frameworks
which accounted for about 40% of the
boats that were patched in last year's
monthly security bulletins will now be
updated by Google on all new devices the
launch with Android Q and device makers
can also have to choose to have
conscript which is androids TLS provider
also updated directly by Google with
this in place future bugs affecting
these components can now be fixed much
more quickly across the entire ecosystem
so we don't leave our users vulnerable
to learn more about this we published a
blog post yesterday on the Android
developers blog so take a look at that
to find out more and finally hardening
Android leverages Android leads
ecosystem in leveraging compiler level
mitigations such as sanitizers control
flow integrity and hardware ACN and many
more to harden the operating system and
Android q we expanded the usage of these
techniques in the kernel as well as the
most critical parts of the user space to
significantly reduce the potential
exploitability of bugs in these areas
now these horny tools can also be
leveraged by apps for example for apps
that target the Android q API level
you'll now have execute only memory
enabled by default this marks marks
memory regions executable memory memory
regions as not readable which
strengthens a SLR address space layout
randomization to learn more about
hardening we have a blog post coming out
in the next couple of days to the
Android developers blog okay so that was
a quick overview of how the operating
system is becoming even more secure with
Android q now the developers in the
audience probably came here to learn
more about what we can do to make our
apps more secure
so we're building upon so last year we
launched industry-leading API such as
strongbox and protected conformation and
this year we're building upon upon that
momentum so for the remainder of this
session we'll cover a few topics in
encryption and application signing keys
and in user authentication we'll also
cover a couple of really exciting areas
a couple of really big areas that we're
working on that promise to be very
impactful in the future okay let's now
dive into the first topic encryption
this is an area where we've gotten a lot
of questions from developers over the
years developers want to know is my data
actually encrypted on the device now the
answer has always been fairly
complicated while the vast majority of
new Android devices fully encrypt user
data there are a number of low-end
devices such as Android Go devices sold
primarily in developing markets that use
low end hardware and don't have hardware
acceleration for encryption and so
encryption on those devices causes
noticeable slowdowns and makes the
device hard to use and this affects not
just phones and not just Android devices
smartwatches
Internet of Things appliances and
similar smart connected devices often we
use the same hardware as in phones and
so they inherit the same hardware
limitations to address this we set out
to create an encryption mode that can
run fast without additional hardware and
the result is a danton adiantum is a new
encryption mode created by Google
engineers at cryptographers designed
specifically for disk encryption on
low-end armed devices it has a couple of
very nice properties first adiantum was
designed to run based using only
operations that all CPUs natively
support so it doesn't need the turtle
hardware and our benchmarks running
purely on CPUs adiantum runs five times
as fast as a es which is the standard
cipher used on android today and so
besides being fast from a security
perspective adiantum only uses
well-known
to graphic primitives with well-known
security properties and because we
developed it fully in the open we got a
lot of input and feedback from the
worldwide community of security
researchers help us make sure that it
works correctly and so besides being
fast and being secure addy Anthem now
levels the playing field for all Android
users while high end devices premium
devices with specialized hardware will
always have an edge in speed as well as
some security properties low end devices
now also have a tool to help them
encrypt and secure their user data so
now with Android cue a hundred percent
of compatible devices launching with cue
will now encrypt user data with no
exceptions so this includes
all form factors supported by Android
including the phones in your pocket the
tablets that your kids may be playing
with the Android based TV that may be in
your living room and the Android auto
based car that you may be driving so
this is a huge milestone for Android and
beyond Android it's also a huge
milestone for the entire community
adiantum is fully open sourced and has
been merged into Linux 5.0 and so in
today's world where computation is
increasingly moving to the edge often to
low power devices device makers
regardless of whether you're running
your devices is running Android or not
now have a new tool to help secure your
user data
okay so adiantum is great for new
devices but device makers in the
audience you probably have apps that
need to run on older devices as well and
so you need a solution for encryption
that runs everywhere now unfortunately a
righty an encryption layer is far from
easy and mistakes are common mistakes
such as we're using nonces or not having
enough entropy in your key generation
and what's worse is that these mistakes
often go unnoticed until an incident
happens and so this year in order to
make that easier
we have built a security library into
jetpack
thank you the Jeff had security library
was built based on our experiences
talking with developers talking with all
of you about your top pain points and
the goal here is to make common tasks
80% of the most common tasks really easy
to get right these tasks include
encrypting files encrypting shared
preferences and securing our API keys
and under the hood the Jeff Hawk
security library handles all the boring
details for you
such as creating and managing your keys
and secure hardware and we use industry
standard best practices that Jeff Hawk
security library is in alpha this week
and supports Android 6.0 and above so if
encryption is a pain point for you take
a look and give us your feedback okay
so we've not now talked a lot about
encryption of your data at rest with
adiantum with a jetpack security library
now what about encryption of your data
in transit your network traffic last
year we launched DNS over TLS which
encrypts your DNS traffic and this year
we're improving HTTPS by enabling TLS
1.3 by default TLS 1.3 is a new revision
of the TLS standard finalized by the
IETF and August of last year it is
faster because it can often complete the
connection handshake and fewer round
trips making connection times of up to
40% faster it's more secure because it
removes support for problematic features
and it uses a redesigned handshake that
fixes several weaknesses and finally it
is more private because it it encrypts
more than the goshi asia and handshake
to protect the identities of the
participating parties now how do you use
TLS one for three and Android for web
browsing modern browsers such as Chrome
and Firefox have already enabled support
for apps if your app uses chrome custom
tabs or webview then you'll also be
using TLS 1.3 by default if the server
supports it regardless of the Android
platform version that you're running on
and then on your on Android cue if your
app uses
built-in TLS provider called conscripts
then you'll also be using TLS 1.3 by
default regardless of your apps target
API level
okay so encryption is getting better the
next question to ask is is anyone using
encryption or apps actually encrypting
their network traffic so we pulled some
numbers and we're really happy to see
that 4 apps in the Play Store targeting
android pi more than 80% are now using
network security config to block clear
text network traffic and another 5% of
apps are blocking clear text by defaults
and with a few manually configured
exceptions so these are great numbers
and a big thank you to all the
developers out there who are encrypting
your network traffic and securing your
user data now if you own one of these
remaining apps that's still allowing
clear text by default please take a look
at your configuration and see if there's
anything you can do to choose to switch
to a safer default
moving forward we'll be adding more
hints and warnings into both Android
studio as well as the Play Developer
console to help developers to ensure
that we're all using encryption HTTPS as
much as possible ok so we've talked
about encryption with your encryption of
your data at rest and capturing your
data in transit let's now switch gears
and talk about application assigning
keys so this is an area where we've
gotten a lot of questions from
developers in the past as well I
personally had meetings with a few types
of developers where this is a huge pain
point the issue here is that there are
some apps in the Play Store
especially that a few that have been the
place were for a long time that are now
using application signing keys that are
no longer is strong enough maybe they
didn't have enough entropy when they
were generated or maybe the developer
has lost access to their keys or suspect
that's been compromised so in order to
make key management easier a couple of
years ago we launched app signing by
Google Play where apps can opt in to
have Google Play manager signing keys
and protected against many types of
compromise since launch we've seen that
a large majority of new apps
now opting into upsetting now while key
management Saudis e'er there remains a
gap for many existing apps who are using
wiki's and need a way to move to a
stronger key and so in order to help
with that this year we're launching key
upgrade for new installs by Google Play
if your app is already using apps app
signing by Google Play and if you're
using a weak key you can now ask Google
Play to manage a second stronger key on
your behalf
and the way that this works is that for
your existing users who already have
your app installed all update to that
app will continue to be signed by the
original key now on the other hand for
your new users and returning users on
devices that don't currently have your
app installed new installs will be
signed by the new key and an update to
that will also be signed by the new key
so this is how we can gradually move
your user base to primarily using the
original key to using the new key for
example when a user of yours buys a new
phone and installs your app on your
phone now you may be wondering why are
we using the new key only for new
installs the main reason here is that
older enjoyed platform versions do not
have great support for key rotation and
so if we try to update your app to a new
version signed by the by a different key
the platform will reject that update and
so this approach of gradually moving
your apps from using the old key to
using the new key is the most
non-destructive now the good news here
is that Android Pi added great support
for key rotation natively into the
platform and place support is coming as
well so in the future on new Android
platform versions we'll be able to move
the new we'll be able to move existing
installs to the new key as well enabling
this feature is very easy first make
sure you've already opted in to app
signing by Google Play then go to the
apps on your page on the Google Play
Developer console and click on request
key of
to get started the rest of the developer
workflow doesn't change you can continue
to upload a single artifact whether it's
your apk or your application bundle and
Google Play will transparently in the
background sign it with either the old
key or the new key and deliver the right
version to the end-user okay before you
enable this there are a couple things to
keep in mind because you are going to be
changing your application signing key
you need to check for dependencies on
that old signing key for example if
you're using any third-party services
that recognize your app based on the
sign-in key you'll probably want to
update them to also recognize the new
key also if you're using any platform
features that depend on the signing keys
such as signature permissions then
you'll probably want to refactor your
app to achieve your objectives in a
different manner now as I mentioned
earlier this is a temporary limitation
Android Pi added in great support for
key rotation natively into the platform
and place report is coming as well so in
the future you'll be able to both rotate
your key as well as continue to use
platform features that depend on the
signing key on new platform versions ok
so we talked about encryption of your
data rest encryption of your data in
transit we also talked about your
automation signing keys let's now turn
to the last topic user authentication
this is another area where we've gotten
a lot of questions from users from
developers over the years and it's easy
to see why there there are a lot of
security sensitive apps such as banking
apps password managers that need to
prevent unauthorized access to their
apps and so they need to authenticate
their users I'll dedicate their users on
a regular basis and we want to make that
easy so last year in order to do this we
launched the biometric prompt a pion
biometric prompts allows apps to give to
use a common interface to authenticate
and so users get a consistent experience
across all of their apps and biometric
prompt is built in a generic way to
support a wide variety of biometric
types such as face fingerprint and iris
since launch we've seen a lot of apps
adopt this and we've also noticed a few
gaps in coverage and so this year we've
updated the underlying framework with
more robust support for face and
fingerprints and we've also updated the
API to support more use cases
so let's now dive in and take a look at
the new features and biometric prompts
in Android Q first biometric pumped now
supports both an implicit confirmation
flow as well as an explicit confirmation
flow the explicit call formation flow is
the default flow and tell biometric
prompt works today in the explicit flow
the user must explicitly do something to
confirm the transaction such as tap
their finger to the fingerprint sensor
or if they're using face or iris they
need to press a button to confirm the
transaction the explicit flow should be
used for all high-value transactions
such as payments now new and biometric
pods in Android q is our support for
implicit confirmation flow in the
implicit flow the user doesn't actually
need to do anything to confirm the
transaction and this is useful if for
example let's say you're a personal
diary app and you want to authenticate
that your user and the user and your
user let's say is using face-off
education now when the users start your
app you can use biometric prompt to
authenticate your user using their face
and transition immediately into a
scientist state without the user having
to do anything so this provides a much a
much lighter weight much more seamless
user experience to your users so the
implicit confirmation flow is best for
transactions that are easily reversible
such as sign in and autofill in order to
select the implicit confirmation flow
call the API on your screen and note
that while the system will do its best
to honor this there are situations where
user confirmation will still be required
okay so this is one great feature by
magic wand today torque you another
great feature is that apps can now allow
give users the option of using of having
more options to authenticate to the app
this is really useful in situations
where biometric authentication
may not work very well such as face
authentication in poor lighting
conditions so in those situations apps
can now give users the option to use
their device pin pattern password to
authenticate to the app which can give a
much better user experience in those
situations now of course it may not be
appropriate for all apps and so apps can
also not allow a fallback and that is
the default flow if you don't have a
fallback you can always use your app
specific methods such as your app
specific password to authenticate your
user okay so that was the second great
feature we'll talk about one last
feature of a biometric Combinator cube
and that is now that is that apps now
have the ability to check on the status
of biometric authentication on the
device so this is useful if for example
you and you are the owner of this
beautiful app on the screen you want to
show this enabled biometric sign and
toggle if and only if the device
actually supports biometric prompts and
the user has enrolled in it so you can
now check for the status of biometric
authentication on that device by calling
the API on the screen alright so that
was a quick overview of what's new for
by my church prompt in android q since
we're talking about user authentication
I have two more pieces of good news
first as of earlier this year Android
7.0 and above is now Fido 2 certified
this means that if you are using web off
n on Android if you're sorry if you're
using your webs if you're a website and
Android you can now use web auth and to
authenticate your user without a
password so your users can use their
lock screen their last great lockscreen
PIN pad and password or their biometric
or their second factor Fido compliance
security key to authenticate to your app
so this allows us to extend the ease of
password list authentication to the web
native apps on Android can access
equivalent functionality by calling the
phyto to api's provided by Google Play
services ok so another piece of good
news is that as of last month
you can now use your Android phone as a
second factor of security key to
authenticate to your Google account now
second factor authentication is probably
one of the most important things you can
do to secure your online account and not
all second factor authentication methods
provide the same security guarantees and
so this integration here hits a sweet
spot in convenience and security today
it works for Google accounts and we're
working on standardizing the API so that
we can standardizing the protocol so
that we can bring it to other websites
in the future all right
so we've spent the last few minutes
talking about user authentication online
we've also done a lot of work to make
user application really easy in the real
world so I like to bring Rene onstage to
tell us more about that
hey Renee my six-month-old son just
turned it just got his first driver's
license unfortunately his onesies they
don't have pockets so he doesn't have a
great way to carry this plastic card
around with him so can we do something
to help him out with that well I would
say six months maybe a bit young to be
driving or carrying a phone but let's
talk about that because I think many of
us have that same usability problem of
having too many things to carry around
so I am joking aside I'm very happy to
talk about a few details on exciting
upcoming areas in Android security the
first is what we call identity
credentials and this is about electronic
ID electronic ID has been an active
topic in research and early projects for
quite a while and before coming to
Google I actually myself have worked for
three years of that space so please
excuse me for being just a little bit
excited about this topic reaching a
level of maturity that allows us to
bring to end users right now what I'm
very happy to announce is that Android
will support electronic identity in the
form that we also call identification in
the physical world that may be the
mobile driving licenses that we just see
here that might also be future travel
documents or simple Club membership
cards now in all of those use cases
Android support will focus on strong
security and privacy guarantees as is
typical with Android we are designing an
open API to allow apps to use such new
hardware and platform support this new
credential ident
identity credential API will support the
development of so-called holder apps
these holder apps are applications that
support a specific form of electronic
identity like for example those mobile
driving licenses those apps are free to
define their own communication protocols
to the verifier or read raps for example
through NFC or
other wireless channels as well as their
communication to the respective issuing
authority of that credential Android
implements a new credential store that
can be accessed through this API and
managers secure storage of all such
provisioned credentials depending on
hardware support this will be backed by
OEM specific secure hardware with
respective attestation as you might know
from key master and strongbox key at the
station now within that credential store
every app that provisions of credentials
has its own private store of attributes
belonging to this particular document
and the store will transparently handle
their secure persistence and access
control for apps that created those
items users will in addition be able to
view a transaction log of all accesses
to their credential attributes to ensure
transparency of those identity documents
in pretty much the same way that the
call log does that for incoming and
outgoing calls now unfortunately some of
the international standards including
the iso working group for mobile driving
licenses that google is also
contributing to have locked down yet at
this point to a sufficient extent that
we were comfortable merging this api
directly into the queue platform however
in the very near future we will be
releasing a new jetpack compatibility
library that implements the credential
store within an app's private data
directory this api is not expected to
change significantly so as soon as this
library is released all developers are
free to start developing such electronic
identity holder apps the library will be
compatible with the vast maturity of
android devices out there in the field
of the moment in future versions we
expect a new hell implementation for OEM
specific backends based on secure
hardware that will be used by a crane
store system serviced and made available
through new framework api's that will
very very closely match the api's that
we will so release in that
comfortability library if the hardware
supports it and to me that's one of the
most exciting parts sir this will also
allow what we call direct access direct
access is using your identity credential
your document even if the main phone
battery is too low to power the CPU and
therefore to boot Android so just using
for example an NFC tap to the reader you
will still be able to use that document
even if they found no longer boots that
of course requires some hardware support
but support for this is already in the
hell and the draft held specifications
as well as the API that you will be able
to start using with that secure hardware
support devices can also give the
highest and certifiable security and
privacy guarantees for users as well as
the issuing authorities now to give a
small sneak peek of what that API looks
like it's pretty simple actually an API
would first create an instance of the
credential store and use that reference
to provision a new credential and you
document as we also say which can
actually have multiple what we call
namespaces in there one namespace could
for example be that draft standard of
the eyes or mobile driving license but
could also be extended within the same
document with another namespace that
could add additional attributes to make
this document a REAL ID travel document
for within the United States after
creating of the provisioning such a new
credential an app can also request a
proof and at the station that all those
attributes were provisioned into the
secure hardware exactly as provided by
the Asian Authority and sent that proof
back to dashing Authority for
verification there now I'd like to
change tack level and move on to the
second upcoming topic that I am very
pleased to talk about which is how we
mitigate against what we call insider
attacks
in the Android ecosystem there are
actually multiple effort starts at goal
but here on this talk I would like to
primarily speak about fervor
transparency on multiple layers now if I
speak about insiders what to actually
mean by that an insider is any person
who has privileged access to information
or resources that is intentionally a
very broad definition it includes
hardware and protocol designers of
course software developers but also
logistics and retail shop personnel in
fact many of you most of you listening
to this talk will be insiders in one way
or the other and that just includes
access to your own app signing key now
with so much complexity so many
stakeholders in the supply chain
contributing to what goes into making a
modern mobile phone modern mobile device
the big question is how can users
actually trust their own device our
answer to that is focusing on
transparency on many layers from
Hardware all the way up to the apps
enter dynamic code those apps actually
load in addition to the app signing up
great key feature that shall when
mentioned earlier in her talk I would
like to dive into two other of those
layers the first layer is the system
layer which contains the main operating
system itself Android has always been
among the most transparent OS by being
open source in last year's Android Pi we
added and to end client-side encrypted
backups to mitigate against insider
attacks on such backups and that even
includes Google servers Google server
administrators in that threat model of
being considered insiders now we go one
step further towards the transparency of
the system by focusing on the software
on the system so after it's running on
the device itself a new version of a vb
tool can now be used to compute the top
level digest of the android system image
if the device is using
standard VP metaphor mod for verified
boot for pixel 3 and 3a phones you can
download the latest factory images and
independently compute this nitrous now
with when the device boots the updated
bootloader will verify this VB method I
chest and all the associated partitions
mentioned within this VB metadata and
pass on the measured hash to key master
running in trust zone as well as
strongbox running under the Titan M chip
this is true for both pixel 3 and pixel
3 a phone's as of today an app can
create the private key in key mastered
or strongbox request an attestation
certificate for those keys and that
certificate will now contain and you
filled with exactly this measured hash
as seen early on in the boots chain by
the bootloader itself before even
passing control over to the Android
kernel now by matching that hash in the
earth station certificate with the one
computed independently and offline from
their official factory images it is
certain that this device is actually
running one of the official factory
images that has passed all the checks
that has gone through all the testing
and not one that may have been modified
for an individual or just a small group
of devices coming at the second layer I
would like to point out here is the
fervor that runs below the main
operating system so if a device is lost
or stolen how can we make sure that data
is safe even when we assume insider
attacks with access to forever signing
keys that is where we add what we call
insider attack resistance on the layers
below device let me quickly explain how
that works the first line of defense is
that cryptographic keys are generated
and stored in secure hardware like the
Titan M chip this is tied into verified
boot and will only make those keys
available for example for device level
decryption for the key that is used for
FB on device when the proper user
knowledge factor
that is pincode password or pattern is
entered by the user however an insider
with access to such signing keys leaked
whatever went wrong there could
potentially create the trojan eyes
firmer that when you update the titanum
or other secure element - that would
make those cryptographic keys available
without performing that verification for
the user knowledge factor with strongbox
insider attack resistance we take the
next step of mitigating against such
attacks by default every update to the
Titan and forever will invalidate all
keys that are stored inside only when
the user knowledge factor is available
during the update itself will the keys
be migrated to work on a new version of
the firmware now if an attacker has a
correctly signed firmware update but
doesn't have access to the user pin
password or pattern they can still force
apply that update to the bootloader it
looks like a legitimate update is
correctly signed it has an updated
version counter and so on they can force
that update to apply but without having
the you to use your knowledge factor at
the same time this will make all keys
inaccessible and therefore be roughly
equivalent to a factory data reset
coming back to the multiple different
layers that I talked about we have to
conclude that every one of those layers
will require different methods to
mitigate insider attacks however
transparency is a key component to all
of them we are trying hard to make it
possible for developers and users to
verify what is happening on every layer
and to audit instead of having to trust
all those parties in that complex supply
chain
whenever reasonably possible we take
ourselves out of the trust equation so
that you don't actually have to take our
word for it but can verify yourself as
app developers we recommend you to
similar analysis of what insider attacks
on any of the components that are under
your direct control could look like and
what you can do to mitigate a
instead we're all in this together and
the open source nature of Android
luckily makes it easier to build this
kind of transparency now thanks a lot
for all your attention on what was a
very dense session with a lot of detail
and special thanks to all of you coming
in here in the morning after a big party
highly appreciative thanks
[Applause]
[Music]